greetings from podcast Ville the church
what's happened now is brought to you by
stamps.com listen these days you get
back to get everything on demand like
our podcast listen whenever you want
when it's convenient for you did you
know you can even get postage on demand
all you need is stamps calm I've been
using them for years to send out coffee
cups
t-shirts posters my wife loves it you
know why because it saves you time and
time is money and energy so what I'm
gonna do is this right now go to stamps
calm before you do anything else and
click on the radio microphone at the top
of the homepage and type in Joey again
go to stamps calm before you do anything
else and click on the radio microphone
on the top of that homepage and type
Joey what I'm gonna do is this I'm gonna
give the church family a special offer a
four-week trial four-week trial
including postage and a digital scale so
go to stamps.com click on the radio mic
on the top of the homepage and type in
Joey that stamps calm and - Joey number
two one of the most interesting products
I've received the last week is the ridge
the ridges of minimalist wallet that
helps you really ate your everyday carry
launched by a father-son team funded on
Kickstarter in 2013 there is now resides
in the pockets of over a quarter million
men and women the RFID blocking wallet
is made by two metal plates either
titanium carbon fiber or aluminum bound
together by durable lasting bond your
credit card your license is just the
stuff that you need it's light I love it
for traveling so what I'm gonna do is
this okay it's sleek it's got metal
plates bound together by durable elastic
band so you will lose nothing you
understand me it's easy its front
minimal that's designed to let you ditch
your bulky wallet what I'm gonna do is I
just want
to go do me a favor right now his family
because you're gonna love it
go to Ridge wallet comm slash Church and
use promo code Church CH you are CH and
what I'm gonna do is today only I'm
gonna get your 10% off with free
worldwide shipping by going to Ridge
wallet comm for right now just go to
Ridge wallet and take a look it is one
of the most interesting products out
there and if you're a traveler you're a
sportsman you ride a bike stuff like
that you don't want bulky stuff
Ridge wall is the way to go so right now
today I'm gonna get you 10% off from
free worldwide shipping by going to
Ridge wallet coms last stretch again
that's Ridge wallet dot-coms last Church
you use promo code Church number three I
just received this in the mail about
four days ago and I've been using I got
to tell you something it's one of the
best brushes my teeth has ever gotten
and even though my teeth are the color
of like a chartreuse this thing work
tremendous one of the most important
things we do for our hunt every day is
brushing our teeth yet most of us don't
do it properly quip is a better electric
toothbrush created by dentist and
designers quip was designed to make
brushing your teeth more simple
affordable and enjoyable so far I've got
nothing but five-star results your teeth
in your mouth feel cleaner it's just
just you know and sonic vibrations and
they gentle enough on your sensitive
gums so do me a favor
for starters you know what I always tell
you go to quick I'm going to quit comm
and see what I'm talking about this is a
phenomenal project product especially if
you're a traveler so what I'm gonna do
is this
I love quick that's why I love quip
because they're back way over 20,000
dental professionals clip starts in just
24 hours and if you get the clip calm
slash Joey right now you get your first
refill pack for free with a quip
electric toothbrush it's a great
Christmas gift I'm telling you right now
you got a girlfriend a wife a husband
somebody don't know that he wanting a
present this is perfect that's
affordable and they'll love your father
so your first refill prac is free and
get quick calm / Joey look at lean boy
a lovely dude if I could [ __ ] heaven
I've had a little bit of a Lehmann and I
could take with me and keep somewhere
and a little like a wheelbarrow but for
lease I poke Liam when it owes breath
sounds nice thank you yeah and pillows
in there - I'm just putting you in there
on the metal that's like some people
would do put you under a warm Lampley I
said I would do starting to get creepy
now something I'm hostage ain't going
down and be a good pet you little buddy
look like a chain around his neck where
the [ __ ] chain hooked to the wall and
stuff like that yeah but a nice chain
like a gold chain I don't know if I go
that hot girl they know go for it you
can't put a silk hat on a pig I'm saying
it's [ __ ] Thursday November 8th kick
this [ __ ] mule weekend man as as good
as it [ __ ] gets the oval praise God
sly the Family Stone no not you the
gristle missile baby
Thursday morning what are you [ __ ]
nuts 20 of life no-parole
fresh from Buffalo New York you didn't
have a [ __ ] beef on WIC I didn't have
any top that I didn't somebody threw a
piece of meat at me tall order street
corners I don't know if that would work
or not read it now which is the roll the
roll is called wick oh no it's nobody
told me that shy should come in here for
your fun way I know like a travel agent
- no no I just know what quality using
wet yeah and nobody makes a bad [ __ ]
beef on wicking Buffalo like it's like a
disgrace for them really yeah it'd be
like disgraceful to make it snow yeah
feel vassal disappointment and get that
[ __ ] thighs [ __ ] Parag using the
Polish neighbors now crap Iraqis fried
like dumplings only you know it's not
cat yeah for people like Leah I'm on a
little bit of cat but you've had Fox
meat Lee I don't think so have you yeah
that Fox where was this it's not much
it's more ligament than muscle but it's
good you know
Fox uh and dude the crazy thing about
Fox I was talking about this yesterday
to some money but dribble hug no we
caught a lot of [ __ ] though and we used
to bury animals we live by like a road
where a lot of animals would get hit and
killed so we bury him you know the first
animals I spent the most time with we're
animals I would have been hit by
vehicles and so I could we would very
mostly dogs what else I think something
else one time this thing looked like a
damn [ __ ] small bear bra and it could
have been you because they have
Louisiana black bears a lot of things
you know and I'm not saying they're
black or anything like that I'm just
saying they happen to be black when
people see them and they're just you
know in awe but we would bury all kind
of animals that would get hit by us what
are you [ __ ] undertake I see on that
animal I leave it the [ __ ] alone it's
bad luck
yeah but it was I don't think it were
alive and they were suffering and you
shoot him in the leg
yeah whatever the [ __ ] you do but if
they're dead this is Department of
Public Works that's in charge of clean
animals yeah but Department of Public
Works up think comes for people that are
paying taxes and people that got you
know they didn't come bus dude they had
some they had a veterinarian or
something or like uh some dude somebody
used to kill throw dead animal carcasses
in a ditch outside of our house right
for like seven years my mother would
call every week well coming over on big
animals to cats and possums in my
neighborhood look I and I wish I would
have had to have never we had somebody
they had a uh I guess this person was a
veterinarian that's somebody that deals
with animals helps animals out and so
this person would come and whoever they
were at night get throwing dead animals
you know instead of paying to get rid of
them they probably cost maybe seven
dollars to get rid of them you know the
whatever I'm sure there's legitimate
thoroughfares how you get rid of animals
but this dudes out there you know
chucking them in the ditch I guess on
his way home because our neighborhood
was kind of a cut-through between like a
nice area in town so um you never did
like a stakeout to see who's throwing
animal carcasses
do we not
no I mean we were out there lie but we
never saw the guy unless he drove by and
didn't throw one out because we were out
there but then what creep kind of sits
next to an animal car he'd probably
throw it out elsewhere but anyway so the
um but anyway yeah my we'd go out there
all the time my mother would call every
week come and get these you know the
kids are out there beating each other
with people chasing each other with
[ __ ] you know [ __ ] horse skulls
and [ __ ] but it was it was at that
Christmas teakettle and if I could serve
and Lee a couple cups right big fart
sponge baby welcome to Africa Lee
normally I like all your the sayings I
don't like the fart sorry
I'm sorry but and I'm just joking about
that I didn't mean that I would never
say it I know it's funny wouldn't it
people take you to it
it's been like two podcasts he farted on
me oh I do need some countries that's up
in Japan that's like a that's like
buying somebody a scarf oh he's got the
thighs of a [ __ ] kung-fu fighter son
do you got to know different
nomenclatures and how to give a pug bra
in Africa they hit you at a [ __ ] pipe
or if they love you get a little air
appetizer brush read your nose tree just
snout to some of that [ __ ] free booty
pasta bread brah oh my god Lee man do it
so funny you know sometime when I'm not
even joking about when I would need to
think about something good you don't
think about Lee man
well thank you that means a lot yeah I
think about you man I think you think
about you too laughs you mean just the
stuff you say randomly I just want to
hang out and like listen to what you say
during the day to yourself i just i feel
like it's hysterical this conversation
game
you write here already I think we might
be a little cask alone oh yeah I know
you're talking about
peppermint they call it the run from
coming out of the closet pretty soon
they say hey you know the boy over there
little little longer [ __ ]
I don't care eat it brah I'll let you
hang off my dick like I'm [ __ ]
Mountain killer I would never let Lisa
not you guys but I I don't have the same
relationship but here but you're still
friends
I'm friend where do we I wouldn't [ __ ]
him out let him touch my dick a little
you know saying down around the holidays
brother so make his day oh he's a prison
ham this guy brah [ __ ] love that boy
you know this one I told
we walked won't walk early one night
mm-hmm
how much money we can make with Leon the
inside just sitting on people's laps
dealing carts and robbing it yeah
bringing this back you can't just sit on
someone's lap but they're not gonna let
it end it just lap sitting brah not in
prison because they live in a urinate
brah won't female think you're Indiana
doc you're a female 10 G's beautiful of
wit guarded oh yeah and just mug is dick
with your [ __ ] neck Lee you got to
get out more get off the internet bro
you got to go hitchhiking man I really
don't I don't want you now
you should go I say well there's a
school project yeah I'm gonna end up
dead but what school are you in you
doing classes online no I need to be
classes here this is the only how old do
you li third you know are you really
yeah I thought you were like 19 dude I
wish are you really 30 years old yeah
you thirty years old
oh my god bro my whole perception of you
I thought you were like a like a you
know he was a kind of in turn first came
in young man that's awesome and now you
don't like me as much join man I don't
know it's just different you ever
noticing you learn something about
somebody you didn't know you know like
you see somebody and they're like a
lawyer or something but then you realize
they're like a sorcerer or a son or they
do say shady [ __ ] you see I'm like
ballroom dancing and you're like this
[ __ ] guy ballroom dances I always act
that always takes my brain a minute or
if you see
big big person and it got their stomach
stapled and now dude I was at a pool one
time nice to work on this farm in the
summer times the ELSA in Natchez
Mississippi and they had a and this dude
don blankenship i'l guy every year right
and he come out there and I keep an eye
on him cuz it dude
weighed probably seven or eight hundred
pounds bro you know what I'm sayin he
broke the gate every time he come in he
[ __ ] it's in the pool trust me nobody's
drowning all the waters out and the
[ __ ] kid who's sick is laying right
there no he was the perfect he was the
guy who came to put the cleaner in the
pool and so but he'd opened the gate
Brian every time he walked through it
and bring both sides of the gate now
like he was just uh he was gonna die
soon you know when you saw him you know
she treated him well and that's one
thing I like sometimes about seeing huge
people who remind you how to treat other
people because you're like oh this
person isn't gonna be alive very long so
you would be extra nice to him and so
but then done once I'm up there laying
by the pool and uh and this skinny guy
comes in you know he could have fit
through the gate with 90 of his [ __ ]
you know quintuplets or whatever and he
comes through the gate and I'm like who
and he keeps talking to me and I'm
thinking the guy's kind of a you know
peppermint hunter bruh you know what I'm
saying a little tender and it turns out
he's don blankenship Lincoln Stein he
got the stomach thing and he lost all
the weight and he was a different person
now he wasn't the same I don't know it
wasn't the same in our relationship was
never the same as when he lost as when
he lost the weight I don't know what
we're talking about think about when
somebody takes away your passion if
you're an either yeah you know it's like
when you first get sober yeah you know I
was telling Brogan the other worse two
words in a person's life is sober and
diet I don't want to be involved in
drugs yeah I don't want to be sober
either yeah I never want to be sober
because it would make my battle my inner
battle too rough yeah I know my limits
was cocaine I know my limits were pills
I know my limits with alcohol
I've known my limits when I was 25 they
think I did after 2500 because I wanted
to play knew my limits right you know
what I went when I got locked up I
couldn't imagine a world where I could
smoke pot Wow you couldn't imagine that
I couldn't imagine ok cocaine I
understand not having a girlfriend I
understand being broke but I never
understood a world where I did not smoke
weed huh when I was 25 years old we've
controlled my mood what did he do for
you think I was in so much pain when I
woke up and I didn't know that then you
never know what when you're going
through yeah yeah you don't know that it
takes 20 years to look back yeah you
know I was thinking about it to learn
how
let's take me a shower that if I quit
calm you tomorrow you would be the sign
back up in college and take a psychology
class oh wow psychiatrist and do
whatever I had to take I'd probably be
65 but at 65 I would help so many people
so deeper yeah because I went through it
yeah this is not somebody who studied it
I went through it wrote about it looked
at it I think about it I think about
what made you I broke it down from the
macro to the micro well you could put
yourself in there you could put them in
your shoes and vice versa when you
become a comedian yeah if you're not
brutally honest with yourself it's not
gonna end well
Wow and in life in life in general
yeah head about comedy and life in
general if you're not brutally honest
with yourself it's not gonna pan out for
you yeah you have to be brutally honest
and a lot of people can't be honest
brutally honest with yourself like this
is not gonna work you know it's like I
want at 2729 like him with fat like at
the age of 30 yeah I was I had made
decision
a decision to do comedy yeah but I also
had to make a decision about this hell I
was living in I was living in this party
out okay drugs and this going to be
clean for three days oh yeah and then
snap one night and then tell myself how
this was the last time yeah I wasn't one
of those [ __ ] at a party that was
talking about it and by this time I was
partying by myself and this went on for
maybe a year and a half yeah and I think
by 1995 and a half I came to a
conclusion like they say in the program
then you're a [ __ ] junkie yeah and I
had two decisions to make I know I could
either be a junkie and keep fighting
this but the reason why I became a comic
was to be a junkie I want I read that
Lenny Bruce book and that's the reason
why I got into comedy so if I'm gonna
get the comedy let's make a deal how do
cocaine three times a week
mm-hmm and that's how it started I just
came to terms Wow so you're thinking I'm
gonna get into comedy so I could do
cocaine I was thinking I wasn't gonna do
comedy to have a life I read that book
we slept with strippers yeah he opened
up jazz musicians and I was content with
that and I know that books we talked
about being rich yeah okay no part of
that book they talked about being rich
they talked about money he looked at the
Chelsea Hotel he just talked a life
about being what was happy for him yeah
and at that time that's all I wanted had
been through a terrible marriage I had
already done time so I was just seeking
to be happy but I knew I had a mend
inside could you was a real yet a
deviant soul your soul was pretty sound
like kind of I bifurcated I was living
you know this wasn't who I was I was a
nice Catholic boy who I believed in
heaven in hell and I had a belief system
your inside didn't match all your
behavior right by inside the nuts right
that added to it yeah so no one has that
now I had to have been in a conflict
with drugs [ __ ] you
this is who I am I've accepted it yeah
and whatever happens happens that's it
no [ __ ] big deal nobody guess they're
feeling nice drugs again Lee found one
huh you find an
boy welcome to Easter bruh y'all killed
Jesus here he comes back Blake and he
brought a dirty bag of [ __ ] baked ham
out of a [ __ ] cave this smells worse
than your necklace smells like the
game's feet to the Walker yeah boy it's
not like [ __ ] Thanksgiving nice
prison shower shoes off at night and
sleep on Cantina what's that little
summer camp but smell like they been
walking for 20 [ __ ] days those poor
people
Oh hundred Oh walk 30 hours in a twenty
five days and they're really coming what
are they gonna do up here do you think I
think they're trying to seek asylum you
know living in Honduras El Salvador
right now those are not good places
deliverance a man yeah my father's
Nicaragua you know they're my father's
real name if you know anything about
Central America I know like your
salvador is the price is high they're
killing people down there you know
there's a lady who I talk to from time
to time when she told me she goes only
for Christmastime and then she has a
house down there but she can't retire
down there oh wow
because they just kill you on the
streets you should there's more murders
something like that that effect so I
don't know if it's all sour I'm just
gradually but right but well yeah if
that's your neighbor things can be great
where you are if that's the neighborhood
you're in you know that's heartbreaking
it's a different you know it's like when
you read the Roberto durán book you know
he grew up on the street so come anima
you know he grew up with this guy that
was called no magical with some [ __ ] and
the guy was like a shaman and he taught
about a hustle on the streets on them on
the streets you know that Central
America you know if you ever watched
Miami Vice either the second or third
episode of Miami Vice I read the book I
think doesn't there's no there's no
[ __ ] book cousin is Miami there's an
interesting scene where was the drug
dealer Cuddy there's a drug dealer
cutting the deal but he's got like a
coin yeah at his hand and what happened
it was like four eight-year-old Jews
over the world in different corners
Jesus magic trick no no no he's talking
a business deal it's like you coming to
me
and you want to buy 20 kilos of blow
okay and what are the little boys doing
yelling they're like [ __ ] assassins
oh really
the eight-year-old assassins that come
from [ __ ] Hut's with their family
Jesus and they're just waiting for their
next assignment they're all probably
packing a gun or a knife and they got no
shoes on but this drug dealer playing
with a coin and he would talk to the
people at the way I'm talking to you and
then from time to time I would just flip
the coin in the air when that coin
landed one of those shoeless kids would
run out and [ __ ] pick it up like it
was of watch wow you know and I remember
thinking years later about that scene
the help that's how you know Pablo
Escobar's got those kids to love him and
in Colombian yeah he went to the poor
kids that had no options and he said no
no put a thousand in your pocket every
week but you're gonna kill [ __ ]
for me just like that no questions asked
but it gave him a feeling of purpose you
know I mean money talks and [ __ ]
walks
you at the end of the day money talks
and [ __ ] really does I can blow
smoke up your ass or I could put two G
notes in your week and your hand every
week but you've never had a dollar bill
again yeah and tell you look I'm just
gonna send you to people's houses
yeah I want you to slit their throats
kill their kids their mothers the dog
Jesus let's take our goldfish I want you
to poison them to Jesus you know that's
that's how do you think rat poison or
something whatever it's disappoint the
[ __ ] point I'm trying to make that
that's how you get God you don't take
the an American ghetto here you know
that's why they call it or whatever
social social color economic they call
the Christ it's not a crisis it's coming
from somewhere poor yeah and what you
need to do to get out of that situation
yeah you don't know anything better man
and yeah you just I mean I do dad this
guy when I was growing up named Eddie
right mm-hmm and he could have been
[ __ ] 13 and he could have been about
Miss 16 or [ __ ] 50 right I don't know
what he was but he always drove he had a
5.0 Mustang you know or he drew 5.0 on
the side of it or whatever
remember it could have been a [ __ ] it
could have been a you know a Pontiac
Renault or whatever I don't know what it
was but he always had these two girls
bro sitting on the back of it and I do
was the king you know whatever he said
when I was a kid we would have done it
cuz to him he was the king he had a
money hit a piece-of-shit Mustang but he
had the Mustang you know and he was a
champ and he would buy you know the
chicks would have like daiquiri drinks
Brian whatever you know they need floor
and one of them we go rolling out the
[ __ ] back right on the concrete what
do you do for a living I don't know and
I didn't care but if he would have said
something to do like come do dick like I
when I was a kid I would have done
anything he said cuz he hung out with us
and he spent time with us you know he'd
throw the football around with us and he
was a good guy I think you know I mean I
still think he is a good how old are you
he probably maybe 7 8 10 12 years but he
like could drive he had like the ability
you know he had a car he had women he
had you know he had things that when you
were you know an adolescent 12 years old
11 years old you see that you're like oh
this guy has mobility you know this guy
has ability this guy has women he has
everything so anyway I'm just saying I
can see how it should yeah you know
you're not thinking about anything else
when you're that age and you have none
you're young you get influenced oh I
wouldn't get influenced mm-hmm but I'd
look at guys there was this guy that I
hung out with that was always at the bar
in the daytime he was really
good-looking mm-hmm not Samuel huh
no no if I was 17 he was probably 22 no
I think this guy's a little older than
and it was uh it was a bunch of guys
that hung out but I'm thinking about him
in particular and he drove a Corvette
they didn't have a job and what his scam
was he worked after year and then the
other half in those days you would
collect an important oh yeah you get a
boss that would tell you I'm gonna lay
you off for six months like an informant
party cripples AZ column by UGS then
you'd either take book or sell coke and
that's a great living cuz you clear in
1600 a month already
you sell coke making you know and this
guy would drive a Corvette
he was a piece of [ __ ] he was the piece
of [ __ ] he probably was he wasn't a
piece of [ __ ] he was even had no career
Ryan said he wasn't a role model his
girlfriend owned the business
mmm and she had money yeah and I
remember how that appealed to me for
about a month and I was like there's no
appeal in that I want my own money right
you know I'm saying like you learned
through life like for a month he
impressed me mm-hmm
did he had a girlfriend that paid the
bills mm-hmm but even at that early age
I mean he knows me right because he
ain't paying the [ __ ] bills not that
I could pay the bills at that time
either I grind ain't no bills I was 40
but it's just crazy the people that you
look at and you're impressed with you
know it's like when you watch those
[ __ ] movies like I was watching the
other night Empire was up mmm
they'll watch Empire like the worst drug
movie in the world but it's it's on
Beatty once a month it's one of those
movies that's always on between seven
and nine you got a spot at the store
10:30 oh yeah and you got no choice but
to watch it because there's nothing else
on [ __ ] TV yeah it's either that or
bull racing live from Bulgaria [ __ ]
and there's one scene where a guy goes
up to him John Leguizamo's like the
street drug dealer yeah then he goes up
to me he's like a minute I really wanna
can I touch your deal and he goes I
wanna I want this new Playstation behind
me John goes how much is it he goes it's
a $300 the kid goes three houses the kid
wants the money to do the guilty he goes
no it's $12.99 and Leguizamo goes I'll
give you the money but you gotta do
stuff for me oh yeah you gotta clean my
car so help me God if you you know like
he's telling him what he has to do when
he lies in the games like that you know
those kids grow up wanting to be a
junkie oh yeah yeah this right that's
the first person they get first personal
guest yeah
yeah that's interesting your first
influence how does that yeah where that
first influence is not your dad how much
that influences you that's interesting
it's really weird and it happens with
comedy it happens in anything that you
but it happens when you're a young man
oh yeah I was confused
[ __ ] this twenty would at 21 I was
confused as [ __ ] oh yeah cuz I didn't
want to work
I wanted a [ __ ] new car I wanted money
and I wanted [ __ ] and I want a coke
what was the work Joey sure anything and
I really thought that the [ __ ]
Bluebird happiness it's gonna just drop
it off at my door Wow
like I like a look use both of the eye
right now I'll tell you like I had no
idea about hard work I wasn't a lazy
person right but I work what's the work
yeah why don't I try to put something
together so I can hang out the bar in
the daytime and I don't have to go to
work I mean that was my deal from day
one these long as I didn't have to work
in the daytime yeah do you ever think
that like you know you wanted to arm you
know have like a you know like a uh do
you ever think that you wanted to have a
[ __ ] man I forgot I was going to ask you
you don't even smoke weed them you
better get your [ __ ] together start
smoking is what happens if you get sober
you get [ __ ] where'd you go to
college for they get stupid
that's like [ __ ] Michael Corleone E&C
at the end of the Godfather damn and I
couldn't have any idea coming to my head
man no I think it's funny how yeah what
your influencers are you know the first
person you see do this for that but then
yes sometimes you are able to see past
that like yeah there's some people you
know we had this dude by us mmm like you
know and this guy now runs a tree
company right this guy's centered a lawn
and he he had a dude days to do this one
where they had a lot of sinkholes I grew
up around a lot of sinkholes you know I
mean you'd have somebody you play
hide-and-go-seek and somebody [ __ ]
you never find you know you [ __ ] you
go not like you know you go knock on
somebody's door next to hit her whole
[ __ ] house is gone you know it's like
I grew up in a lot of Louisiana like
half of its sinking you know it's like a
sinking environment so were you from in
Louisiana
Covington Covington Louisiana were
coming is about 50 miles north of New
Orleans that's it yeah did they get
affected by Katrina
yeah yeah everybody lost their roofs
that's a big like over there there but
the house
falldown people lost their roofs so when
you were growing up what was Covington
like was it a [ __ ] deathbed was the
project's was it middle-range
no it was a hat your parents have a
little bit of money enough to sustain
know my dad was [ __ ] oldest [ __ ] dude
I think he was always sleeping on the
couch used to go drink at this bar
called Tony Pedone he's and he would
take me over there during the day and
the lady would say I'm Lee chocolates
like I put in my mouth one of the
bartenders back there big Jan it was
[ __ ] I think there is the Jew you job
nice clothes my mother dressed as poorly
man I don't know where she learned a
dress I got of an Indian shopping like a
Native American catalog if you need for
sure did you need no it wasn't like you
lived off and me down or anything so
covington is not like you know some
[ __ ] neighborhood that's you know
where your dog is missing no I lives off
like I got hand-me-down clothes but I
didn't get hand-me-down shoes like every
year my mother got us a pair of shoes
you know my mom did the holidays with
your mom do for a live
delivery he delivered what newspapers
cookies magazines what about you guys
you some amazing called news on wheels
you remember that magazine you go to a
dime store whatever the gas station my
dad didn't do anything well oh you know
my dad used to do actually this is funny
he used to go to the guy he used to go
to colleges remember they had to do to
the colleges that would sign people up
for credit cards you know some [ __ ]
old dude barking over there throwing
frisbees at kids and [ __ ] you know said
that my dad had that job this towards
the end of his life my parents weren't
together anymore but my dad had that job
and he would take me there with him he
let me drive him I'm 12 years old right
I had a little growth spurt I was that
510 that [ __ ] lean bad boy you know
ligaments only son dude sometimes I want
even bones part of me was just ligaments
reaching out and hoping that the marrow
caught up you know that's the kind of
guy what what did your dad do for a
living before I don't he used to be like
a travel agent you know he did a lot of
crew like he wouldn't sign people up for
cruises and stuff between porta viar-toe
where's that at
Mexico yeah between Mexico and America
and the geography
yes Central America
Christ I got a deal with you I walk in
his room I can't think not know why
others even though that dumb [ __ ] yeah
so they're in the Central America and he
would he was like a travel agent I guess
what do you do when he was young he
wrote for the newspaper
you know he had a family he you know he
was kind of European in a lot of ways he
liked to be you know he worked with the
church he liked to do a lot of he like
to just sit at like the coffee place and
talk you know I think he drank a good
bit how do you feel about religion at
this point you're like my need I need a
higher power you know and I you know for
me what were you raised
I was raised probably Christian you know
sort of definitely I mean but nothing
heavily I just always wanted there to be
a higher power you know I used to pray
at night and that sort of thing but you
know now I just needed to be a higher
power because I want to have faith you
know otherwise I feel like you feel
alone a lot there you go hit him with
that [ __ ] Christmas hit or bra that
[ __ ] war on you [ __ ] that [ __ ]
booty Star of David that era calamari
this is not even Frank an Aqua Velva so
yes I got the vanilla I switch them you
accidentally buy strawberry less the
worse you get out I got Mexican
chocolate over now Champa talk to
hooking the video she's not bad either
by switch the vanilla today the Mexican
chocolate you reach in for the scoop and
a knife [ __ ] positive carry at the
end the carry when she grabs I head for
the rocks what's the matter with this
guy
what about you [ __ ] farted on me
three times in 30 minutes you were
having Wow yeah make a wish yeah
you know about 300 you've welcome
blowing his food out his eyes are
starting to [ __ ] heat up dude I'm
sorry Lee man I feel like I'm being rude
no don't be goodbye he loves all this
[ __ ] yeah if there's no bring in that
wheelbarrow go get that Wilbur oh and
it's got pillars in it to be nice and I
put you out under a lamp like how old
were you when you were driving you dead
to campus dude I was 12 years old so
that put him at 80 yeah he was 82 so he
was driving he'd sleep on the way there
I'd stop on my buddy's house dude long
as he was rested I guess I was [ __ ]
showing off I had a delta 88 suddenly my
friends are still you know going through
adolescence you know inside trying to
you know blow a flute to get their dick
to [ __ ] get taller you know like they
see on those commercials in India and I
can hear I am pulling up you know in a
in a Cutlass and a Delta 88 I go in on
my posh come out get in the back seat
let's go for a ride right so my buddy
Scott get back there and we would just
[ __ ] cruise around do my dad sleep
and and hear the thing my dad's neck was
real bad too even if he woke up I would
just tell Scott keep it quiet back there
for a minute you know I'll just tell him
we're lost or getting gas or something
today my dad would go back to sleep and
I cruise around a little more and then
take my buddy back I mean get it 12 13
years old a friend picking you up we
pulled up with a sleeping senior citizen
do people thought that we were [ __ ]
kid hug kidnappers bras senior citizen
kid last time you blow up on time [ __ ] I
think maybe we smoked the cigarette but
there one time brother there wasn't time
I do remember this I'm driving back from
Hammond Louisiana and oh so this how I
kind of got in a fight I got in a comedy
but this the first time ever really
spoke in front of people's my dad would
get people to sign up for the credit
cards and he got a dollar-fifty from the
company whatever any college kid the Sun
up and now looking back it's like
getting college kids to sign up for a
credit card he probably started half at
a [ __ ] you know you know he probably
ruined a lot of people's young
that's what they do what they do that's
what they want to do they want to tangle
you up at 19 right so did you take that
first story alone you getting correct
yeah
Esther it's automatic you got your name
goes I don't list the eligible so I'd be
on the table my dad would have me on the
table and people come over and I would
start barking at them getting them to
come over you know hey you you know you
know guy with the nice haircut or
something or the black girls a lot of
times you know they have all the extra
hair you know I'm talking meat of a girl
of a [ __ ] rope swing Annie hanging
off the far side of her [ __ ] head you
know you got summer campers swinging off
the back and jumping into a river you
know black girls have that long extra
hair and you'd see them and you like hey
you know and be sweet to them and have
them come over and and you would make
friends and you would be entertaining
and you get them to come over and then
my dad would try and sign them up for
the credit card you know you know what's
crazy
Theo you just make move Miami so it's so
weird how people saying like that
chicken that people don't know that
chick Flo mm-hmm that that girl that got
all those commercials oh yeah sorry I
saw her I don't know additional one that
and it's funny that Flo was packed up
and get rid of leave this town and she
booked that campaign now she's a
gazillion a hell yeah you know and it's
so weird that Josh wolf left Seattle in
September he's a funny guy of 96 this is
what a nice guy too huh and my plan was
for him to come down at that time we
were very tight and my plan was for him
to come down check out the waters and I
would come down in eight or nine months
and once I made that decision mm-hmm
like all these opportunities started
opening up for me the first one being
and I got this job so he went first
he came first September in 96 he left
his girlfriend up debt and I lived in
the back house and she was pregnant so
he came down here first to get them set
up I lived in this bad guest house with
just you and a lady it was that scary
they had kids I ain't sure one of the
kids I was tight with her she was a
great lady right okay
I just haven't seen
we were dear friends yeah cuz he's
married to a different woman now Ben
yeah yeah I'm completely different
medicine so he came down first right
away I got this job
yes company that I know people and those
[ __ ] this was a cigarette company no
this is [ __ ] this was a [ __ ] idea and
they paid me $15 an hour plus bonuses
this is 1996 Jesus which is 20 years
very good money one years ago
that's great money and what it was was
calling pizza parlors across the country
and getting them to sign up for a
service that a half-time it was a chain
that's what it was that's what it was it
was Domino's Pizza it was a scam no
Domino's Pizza I cut a deal with the NFL
mm-hmm that during a game if a Domino's
sign came up on your screen you got $1
off a pizza hmm but to get that deal you
had a son like Domino would make its
affiliates pay so I had to call those
affiliates and make them pay that extra
money to get so what it would do is as
soon as they called Domino's that number
it would go to whatever Domino's paid I
say this was a scam inside of Dominus
right it was like yet I work for a
Domino's affiliate that was calling
Domino's and saying listen we'll start a
new program starting August 14th yeah
and here's the deal
every time people watch another phone
game this would be abdominal banner on
the side and say call now get too long
oh yeah I remember that fresh delivered
pizza make sure the hot beats on the
screen don't sign up for that
the calls won't go to your pizza joint
right the calls are golden the pizza
joint in [ __ ] North Hollywood man I
registered no hot really shitty to see
what the corporation was doing from
within but I didn't give a [ __ ] right
yeah you can't fight that battle
I could sell like a [ __ ] I so I
was pulling down I was born after I
watch of the week growing
9 oh how why do you ever quit that 35
hours a week like 10 the [ __ ] floor
like something easy this is what I'm
saying I quit that job a step because
one then at the [ __ ] the underground
a guy approached me and he goes hey man
at John's Club you have been a the old
calendar girl and John Fox is home yeah
John pots his old man that's a great
runner says no no this is 95 there's a
completely different room
it was differences on the swanee yeah
and some guy came up to me and he goes
ain't men did you ever sell before like
yeah you know I saw whatever and he gave
me a job selling phones mm-hmm that was
just too good to be your hey phones pay
phones so I would cell phones and
advertises that newspaper at the same
time you know me dog I'm a scam why
don't I buy phone from you right now
anything not to [ __ ] have a day job
yeah so I would hang out by the train
station mmm-hmm and I will need to sell
your subscription for the Seattle Times
hmm why would I ask you do you have a
cell phone I would take the song of cell
phones cell phone and he gave me a
cellphone little limited minutes now in
1997 yeah you were king out of it and if
you call like an advocate if the guy was
giving me like it for every line that I
opened huh the guy would give me like
400 bucks and he was kept like 16 I knew
that this time she he told me the truth
he was wrong I'm making that much money
because if somebody bought I followed
and got a line the company this is 97
before people are having a lot of pitch
from right yeah this yeah so cell phones
so phone yeah the cell phones were a
little bigger yeah I didn't get her cell
phone until itself until 2000 so if you
signed up there was a kickback the guy
would give me a kickback
it's huge I was going over there
everything giving him seven eight
numbers even close to real formal Wow
and I would stand the more I can't
believe I just remembered that I would
stand at the mall I'd either and while
buying stuff I've written more know I
was by dick I would be that guy than the
wing bones
a real way
when it was raining I would go to the
everybody rub know that would sell
[ __ ] subscriptions to either The
Washington Post The Seattle Times oh
yeah or a [ __ ] cell phone and the
cellphone was paying me [ __ ] it was
just amazing yeah the guy would show up
every server it's at the [ __ ]
underground give me 1,500 I was like
jesus [ __ ] intervene I can't even
imagine so the whole month of December I
was making money so did you even want to
come and do comedy than what you got
that money I would have kept that no I
kept I needed that money I was paying
child support I was paying an attorney I
wasn't [ __ ] so much debt it was
coming out of my eyes plus I was
snorting blow but now I'm making six
seven thousand a month sounds [ __ ]
cell phones and a mall every [ __ ] day
and now Doug Stanhope comes for New
Year's and I open up for him he talks me
into moving to LA so my point is that
it's really weird how places trick you
right when you say to the universe I'm
gonna leave you get the best job in the
[ __ ] yeah when I love Seattle I was
pulled down sixteen hundred a week just
selling cellphones
never mind [ __ ] blow subscriptions to
the Seattle Times
if I had let the do I'd say you know
you're pushy lined up or you know I
lived with a stripper a little girl that
made money and she iPads with the rent
with her we lived in a [ __ ] wheel
[ __ ] and I no no we were she stripped
and she was Christian so I slept that
said different beds like [ __ ] the
Dick Van Dyke Show we lived in a [ __ ]
RV we live in an RV at a place where you
back your RV up yeah they connected oh
yeah cable TV you got you had a shower
in your RV or or they had an Athletic
Center this place was tremendous
oh my god it was there for 20 years it
was a collage koat or something it was a
good kid no a little bigger it had a
bigger name a better reputation yeah bro
that restaurant was a crazy breath walk
in they had three or four restaurants
real restaurants they had a gym a pool
shower what was it a movie theater in
Kent Washington where [ __ ]
you know was was living in Kent
Washington at the time Henry Hill know
where Henry Hill was living problems
jeffrey dahmer when he from there at the
white know he's from Milwaukee Wisconsin
[ __ ] I'm thinking we can't the
Washington had a [ __ ] RV park yeah
with the stripper in an RV and a dog
what a lucky guy Midway mobile villas
mobile man it's not trying to sell you
the name believable they wake up in the
morning walk into the building we brush
our teeth I give her a stab and we'd
walk into the building wow-whee two eggs
sunny-side up eggs like nothing at the
diner
they had a diner in there then we go
back to the thing watch TV for a while
I'd write timely and then we both go
into the gym over this when yeah we'd
slow down cuz that's how you have to
take a shower you took a shower cause
you had a working place yeah in those
days I was homeless so for me to take a
shower I'd have to work out oh yeah I
work out twice a day I was tip-top
[ __ ] Google I loved that when I moved
to LA I was in great shape it's what
happened to me I fell apart with once I
got II I stopped doing everything but do
you so now I'm thinking about this while
you're telling me that so I'm like you
know that when you say so when you when
when you start to tell the world or you
know you tell like the powers in the
world you're gonna move the universe
when you tell the University you're
gonna move that that's when the universe
like starts to give you things to keep
your little curveball that you write
they throw a curveball so then you gotta
be somebody that then you I mean that's
like that's kind of is that the
difference between some people and other
people you think that you you're willing
to just say okay look these are great
things but I'm gonna still move away
from this and take my chance that cuz
some people would just stay do you think
like there's something inherent in
certain types of people that are then
like okay I'm gonna put this on the line
and still move there are people that
will come to me and say to me Joey I'm a
comic I'm moving I'm putting away money
and moving to LA in two years that guy's
dead doctor
is dead yeah that's never gonna happen
you got to build us somewhere else
that's know that were you saying when
you have the urge to make a move you
have to make a move
oh I see what you're saying the people
procrastinate that move will give you a
reason why yeah they're looking for
something before on their lap so I don't
have to move saying they're gonna get
itself genius pay no they give
themselves a two-year span and what
happens you meet some fat chick you
knock her up yeah now your dream is
quashed because you got married so you
gave yourself without yeah sometimes in
life we gives ourselves our own happen
yeah but sometimes the universe gives
you an ounce and you have to take
advantage of it you know the universe
will give you signals yeah don't tell
your science you know if I have up to
you if a bounce ask to come to you to
tap you on the shoulder to tell you it's
time to leave yeah you [ __ ] up yeah
you don't want to put the drink down and
get up and walk out of there ya know
this because you're an adult and because
you've seen how people have acted once a
town like I've overstayed my welcome
yeah because I've overstayed my welcome
I realized when it's time to go right
this time the door was time standing out
this time I know what it's time to go
I'm the king of Norwood I'm the guy
there was a place I used to rob
constantly used to work they robbed
constantly yeah I knew I couldn't do it
anymore
because I was gonna get caught and my
reputation and my life was gonna be [ __ ]
again mm-hmm I forced myself to quit I
took a 50% pay cut yeah he was stealing
right because I was stealing but I knew
eventually I would get caught there was
no because that's the way like drinking
water
smell that [ __ ] this [ __ ] you guys are
like a married couple days no no this is
what sex in your sixties is like dude
yeah huffing somebody's movie
poorly he's been sniffing twice
isn't that what signal to his t-shirt he
said a man we in our area to add a lot
of sinkholes right because Louisiana is
8 feet underwater brother if you look at
New Orleanians that city is 8 feet under
it's below sea level so here's the ocean
right then
there's naturally a bottom and that's
where they built New Orleans no that's
so that's why it always floats
constantly there so it's all get
everywhere around like our whole area
Louisiana is a swamp you know but they
had an arm a company for land when they
wanted to build and before they had an
you know now they got the surveyors you
see a dude out there in the morning you
think he's a pedophile he's taking
pictures of children or something but
he's looking for distance with the lame
with the orange vest and made him put
orange vest on because everybody thought
they was you know touching children are
looking for children and now but before
that they had they would hook a [ __ ]
rope to you [ __ ] bird is hatching
what this book is that my farts I'm
smoking it on that's all right now
that's gonna come on like that Kareem
said yeah that's that [ __ ] lunch Ana
make it ricochet off the chair ricochets
off the nine called a ball and it goes
right to his nose he gets them
nobody knows on the farmer I've been
farming like this for 50 [ __ ] years
oh wow I know how to point my hip yeah I
know how to Bank them off the back the
back I know how that oh yes you know
Robert Parish a [ __ ] farts a button
beeps a sec yeah so I could even bang it
off the wall I got like a pool table
right here there's a certain cut I
eliminate hot oh yeah open the door look
at that that's warm air that's coming
out of my ass it's real let's dough
that's how I miss you dude your ass
really [ __ ] hot oh [ __ ] look at Cleo
taking off the shirt and [ __ ] music Leo
Leo Leo [ __ ] come on man slow 25 I've
been held 25 I spoke 25 don't be such a
hard don't be so hard on him but I'm
from you get two letters writing
somebody's name that [ __ ] counts too
if they don't respond after that if you
get one letter right I just felt like
Leo yeah but do so they would put kids
on they this one needs to put kids on
chains and they happen for please walk
out into a field and see if the [ __ ]
earth fell under them that's when I
that's the area I was you know what
Evers advantage kids oh yeah they
definitely did look it up searching for
sinkholes [ __ ] set buttons over here
you know is it road type it in I'm sorry
leave I'm being aloof with ice [ __ ] look
for kids tied up looking for sinkholes
my listen 10-4 what's wrong with you
he's [ __ ] with you I'm not [ __ ]
with a man tie no kids up next thing you
know it's high it wasn't like it you
were kidnapped the [ __ ] forties these
people they would tie Chinese people up
and throw him over the cliff with a
stick of dynamite and that's how they
built the railroads he's [ __ ] huh
yeah man really the Chinese built a
railroad I was a [ __ ] country
and that's how they were tested to see
if it was good land they'd make them go
over the cliff with a stick of dynamite
on a rope or some [ __ ] something [ __ ]
creepy Jesus that's why I don't think
that would be use of white kids to see
if there were sinkholes they had to be
like from other countries or something
like that no didn't have any kids from
other countries boss black kids that was
it and then weren't using them to do
that but they would have kids made it
wasn't a day I mean you wouldn't it's
like you're falling into [ __ ] you
know in the like Haiti's or anything you
would just fall like six or eight feet
you know that's enough some guy felt two
weeks ago to a gonna prattle you gotta
kill three rattlesnakes is you see the
light with this news I'm gonna came out
with blood rattlesnake bites Albuquerque
so far I'm sure I happen the valley
somewhere
this whole [ __ ] town you could be
walking fall into a sinkhole some guy
found to a sinkhole in his front yard he
was swimming [ __ ] dude I could feel it
in my legs if I'm near a sinkhole dude
no joke I could feel it in my legs and
that's from growing up in that area man
you I swear to God you know like you
know how senior citizens know like in
their spine or spinal rattle if it's
gonna rain like you could feel that in
your legs man growing up where I grew up
you could feel if the ground is uh you
know gonna be solid or gonna you know
start to give away I mean you got to
understand how soggy it is in Louisiana
man you guys are it's soggy man you know
the whole state the whole state you
built do you [ __ ] build a doghouse in
the morning it's [ __ ] 30 feet away
you know so what I see in the news all
the time is really like it it rains a
lot in Louisiana as a whole Baton Rouge
mud roll yeah all those towns and the
water just yet though it's so right
there on a sea level you know we're
probably above sea level right here I
bet see we check and see what we are
lead to you mind looking where we are
above sea level in just even if you put
like Los Angeles to do City would not
even what would not we're up a little
bit not you know Colorado up but we're
up yeah you know what what scares me
about Louisiana will do all AIDS as a
whole did they prepare it for another
Katrina I don't think that way they
rebuilt it did they [ __ ] repair it
like that they really no I don't think
they may go back there do you see
anything different I mean I still hear
that this place is thought of just done
from Katrina still areas that are done
they rebuilt a lot but did they rebuilt
it to withstand cuz Katrina's between
the storms it just something get
stronger right and every year we're
gonna get killed it will location
whether it be Galveston Houston you know
Tampa Florida it could be one certain
location yeah it's gonna eventually go
back to New Orleans it's gonna be worse
than Katrina its usual clavering in New
Orleans most people but I don't know
what happened they had they uh I mean if
it wasn't a sinkhole
already after Katrina I would have
knocked that [ __ ] down
filled it with more dirt dirt dirt dirt
you know yeah that's the obvious the
mayor got put in jail Ray Nagin went to
jail he went to jail the chocolate
badgers so that means that means that
the money then get used for fun because
right every Marion always went to jail
right were they feeling they're all
stealing Morial all of the dudes have
always going to jail for New Orleans
yeah how they all corrupt yeah
and when Edwards use the governor of
Louisiana but he was super corrupt that
dude they well yeah it's just a corrupt
place man it's just I kind of you know
it's like pirates and [ __ ] it's a little
bit it's like Tampa but they build a
whole state out of it no I was gambling
around Louisiana yeah yeah gambling
right there in the walls you got all the
boats and you got Harris has a land
casino the only one allowed and they
showed that New Orleans when they got
hammered that they showed that Harris oh
yeah they showed the comic that was
there they didn't know that the comic
that was there during Katrina her
billboard was sideways he was a comedy
store guy oh wow as they was uh James
Stevens the third Wow and he was at that
casino that week had the interesting get
his take on showed Katrina when they
showed New Orleans they showed arrow
sign sideways with his name on it
and that's why I was just really
interesting a big I haven't been to New
Orleans since I I've been to New Orleans
two times but the second time was a lot
better than the first time yeah the
first time is all the most uncomfortable
situations I've ever been in in comedy
wow really
I took my grandma blow and I got the car
drove back to Houston
yeah that's everybody's story and the
hotel was kind of a little weird the
people a little weird when I went back
to shoot grudge match mm-hmm since I
didn't have to go to those weird spots
they're more comfortable it was more
comfortable they put me in a hotel that
was it was a hole they served three
meals a day Wow what do you think is and
it was the food was delicious yeah
the food was out of this [ __ ] world
man Wow
I don't know what the name of the hotel
was
you know you had your own floor Wow
tremendous but I still remember sitting
in the living room like in the dining
room wall like it was like the Last
Supper tape mmm and Here I am all by
myself they gave me the whole floor yeah
show you how to use a card face and
maybe three or four floors five floors I
think uh we're almost downtown a little
bit off the city gonna it was a little
bit off the city and had a you had to be
downstairs from seventy nine to twelve
to two or five to seven to eat dinner D
and they had two or three things on the
menu there was no choice if you picked
one thing it came with a soup salad yeah
it was [ __ ] super Wow and I know that
the one thing we had a party and I went
to the club and it was superb it was
this dirty as I had been the first time
yeah
when I went to New Orleans the first
time it had to be 99 98 well the ones is
out of its [ __ ] mind with Katrina mm
ah no no 2006 when I went to New Orleans
in 98 to do comedy that time I took a
fall out
mm-hmm it was either 98 or 99 and dog I
gotta tell you something from the minute
I parked the car to the minute I walked
in the hotel to walk into the gig I
thought I was gonna get jacked yeah I'm
[ __ ] Mike
you know a lot of my man I've jacked
people right so I felt like I was gonna
get jacked you get the feeling even the
street lights are [ __ ] telling her
you letting it [ __ ] those people at
every corner
it was lookouts yeah people bumping into
you and years later they made that movie
focus about pickpockets and then when
they were number one they gonna
superball Wally Wow and I thought about
that movie how that day I saw
pickpockets yeah too many people bubble
into you a lot of brothers why carry a
lot of brothers with bad intentions you
know it's a black on black crime there
especially at late at night it's crazy
my to drug the situation yeah reminded
me like I'm walking and some guy comes
up like I you know listen you're gonna
do all these you gotta go downtown
you don't say yeah you got to go to the
French Quarter you gotta go take a walk
down there so we got into town maybe to
checked into the hotel and we're right
down there yeah I mean I wasn't on that
block a minute and I got a flashed out
back to 42nd Street yeah in the
seventies where people yeah come in yeah
I mean I gotta go about drinking yeah so
I'm walking I might make him believe
like I'm having a good time there's tons
of people on the street and right away
something that came up to me oh yeah so
were you looking for a play y'all have a
baby carriage full of hope okay I don't
know what you got yeah he knows about
this I got this I got this I got let's
get some cocaine let's see what you got
it doesn't matter I got cocaine I'll
make you dance as [ __ ] yeah you go stand
right here my play oh come over and talk
to you give him the money then I'll come
back when it's all that [ __ ] I even
heard it at the mo yeah that's how it
always is and that happens a lot and I
thought I'd be nicer within four minutes
yeah I got a lot of idiots won't see it
well the tour is still looking for drugs
and they want it fast nasty and they
just gonna get robbed they do that [ __ ]
man I went back to the hotel when I got
to the club the doorman that's me
yeah you get anything why you talking
like we're not give me a grand pow
everything it was beautiful yeah I took
it to the hotel room into the line and
even the front desk people who I thought
were gonna rob me like everybody there
just seems so [ __ ] [ __ ] up it
seemed like a movie I mean I there's a
lot a will [ __ ] me up they knocked on my
door why soon as I got to the hotel room
Oh dad's back took a piss I washed my
hands I took the coca I chopped it up I
opened up a beer I took like two sips
out to be I haven't sit back with me
when to the line of coke dog one little
wine I put the coke away and the door
knocked and when I hoping that the guy
was like oh man I'm just checking up on
you making sure you're okay and I was
like the [ __ ] you doing yeah we're
adults brother coke hit me a little bit
but not enough to make me paranoid it
will [ __ ] me up yeah I called the other
comic I said Dawg what are you doing he
knows nothing that you feel like driving
home he knows I don't want to spend the
night here either Wow
we both got in the car now
after that was mine and I never forget
walking back to the car it was 11:30 and
all I could smell was [ __ ] vomit yeah
oh if you down by the French course if
it's gross it smell like but they're
redoing it now
they're redoing the street yeah I called
you last week you were in new house in
Baton Rouge are you a Baton Rouge I
thought you were New Orleans but dude
even in Baton Rouge man I'm out there
we're taking the kids I got nieces and
nephews you know and their little tigers
and all kinds of [ __ ] you know costumes
and we're taking them and you'd have you
know couple you know brothers running by
like I got coke you know I got coke
gonna squat they're [ __ ] taking the
kids like trick-or-treating you know I
got Molly what you need like what the
[ __ ] that I'm already you know to get
the kid dressed up like a damn Mountain
Lion I'm not doing a bunch of coke at
the house you know he reminded me of
Times Square like there was just patient
mark in that [ __ ]
I got coke I got [ __ ] drywall what
are you got drywall in my hand
look I'm buying that at night the guy I
was with that was driving was a good
nice feature actually he was likely yeah
and he was petrified y'all even think
he's in the business this leaked open
for you now no no no no no I'm talking
about this guy I've been doing it for
like ten years eight years yeah he had a
job yeah and he drove me and he was like
either do drugs and drink he had a
girlfriend
hmm he was a Christian and I'm a
believer that the job he was scared he
didn't feel good yeah he didn't like it
the gig was like a once a month thing
mm-hmm like that it's behind us right
people yeah
that night drunk people problem I didn't
even get it audience they paid you and I
heard maybe a month later they cancelled
it yeah
every time that happens in Louisiana
they don't want comedy man good on one
car because they like to hear the
stories they do nice you go to my cab
Mike what's-his-name had a club down
there my buddy Tommy Pancoast was the
deejay over there and then he ended up
being the gym for a while at the funny
bomb yeah that's how I started I was
there when the girl was dead Chris
Chinese his girlfriend what's the matter
that Shreveport that's oh is that
Shreveport okay does Baton Rouge still
have a club mamrie's doesn't how about
Shreveport it moved over to Bossier
across the river
DuBose your city opened up for Dave
Attell there one time and Tommy I
[ __ ] Andy Dick tried to blow me at
the casino there right then how about
this three years later I'm back there
again Andy Dick's there shooting
something again offered to blow me at
the casino he forgot it offered me three
years earlier and I told him no what a
small world
you know have you Sadie how did somebody
office he had a girl he had a little hit
man so he bait you with that [ __ ] and
then switch it out for his own wiener
well hon I was like his move in such a
girl over yeah you want to come do
something wild or something and then you
come over you know and you'd like be
thinking about her [ __ ] or thinking
about her tits or something and while
you're doing that he'd suddenly he's
there and then they're talking about
like a threesome or something and then
she goes to get you know get something
get drinks or get a salad or something
and then you're [ __ ] sitting there
it's just you and him you know and
you're like [ __ ] this [ __ ] but you know
I'm not doing this
I'm not [ __ ] out here looking for
sink holes for [ __ ] $2 an hour you
should call me a [ __ ] decade ago
Brooke and tied a chain in my back [ __ ]
you dude that to [ __ ] you the exact well
he'll [ __ ] you like a bichon on [ __ ]
on math bra he got arrested again
recently do you know Danny I don't know
he's got a beautiful son no his son is a
fine he's a nice kid Sonny uh Lucas or
whatever his name is how are you gonna
do comedy yeah I met the center company
because the son of other always tries to
do comedy as well Andy Lucas dick is his
name he's a super nice kid he's actually
pretty funny
I don't know if he still does it or not
yeah Angela and I'm not judging I don't
know if he everybody's in their own
world sexual battery what sexual battery
I don't know do bracha [ __ ] add two
charges to it I'm sure I mean it were
triple-a batteries I saw his dick brush
nothing to [ __ ] look at through yeah
he showed me a dude and I didn't look
for a long time I'll tell you that
brother you know is a kind of dick you
could see in one glance like some dicks
you gotta be like oh you got almost look
at both sides to see the real you know
to see the whole city but this thing it
was a little Township right it was
something to have in South Africa Soweto
villages or something
so no the end man a guy tried to in the
car try to grab my dick that's one thing
yeah but a guy picking his dick out
I don't know what I would do I think you
just walk away man
or you say something crazy you know I
wasn't like I'm not like a if somebody
wants to be wild and they're on drugs
I'm not a fine you know here's what
works for me no I'm out brah you know I
don't do all the party meat and all of
that so there's a certain element of
your manhood there's a certain element
of your manhood you know that one day
you decide what you what you are and
what you're not gonna do yeah I have
nothing
again nothing whether you want to be a
transgender if you want to be gay I have
nothing about yeah actual orientation if
you want to play for the [ __ ] Tampa
Bay Buccaneers I don't give a [ __ ] what
okay even Boogie Nights you seen boogie
man yeah you seen only saw it once
though okay there's a scene where the
heroine boy buys a new car and he calls
Markie Warburg to see it and they gotta
mix out with a monkey monkey walk
because what the [ __ ] happened he
doesn't really know and she tricky that
[ __ ] to me like I would know what I do
like if somebody went to make that with
me yeah somebody know what to do what if
they were like a world champion of
something I still would know what like
dude if some [ __ ] you know some guy
who sells you know salads or something
trying to maybe looking at you on the
line of coke and going you know what
feel yeah I love you know this I switch
sides in time to time I think you're
very handsome right I think you would
say to me Joey you're my dog and I love
you but you and me can't bat that way I
don't yeah [ __ ] I think you'd be mad at
me for a week you tell a couple of your
friends but then over the years we'd
forget about it that's one thing if we
were coked up at 5:00 in the morning and
I came clean with you that I banged a
couple guys from time
yeah binaries I got a wife but I'm
bisexual that's yeah but for me to be
snorting coke with here yeah house yeah
I almost like go to the bathroom like
come on you're naked on your couch
hunting fun I gotta [ __ ] you up yeah I
got a wily smack in the face yeah to
make you I don't know I don't know how I
would react I do something I don't know
how to react if you just took your dick
out if you see here's the thing if I've
been around guys who taking their dick
on my black yeah I'm talking about that
I'm talking about me going into a
bathroom me coming back out and woman
you're naked on the couch and you sit
next to me and touch my dick to somehow
am I doing that [ __ ] I don't know I
wouldn't do it I don't know I don't know
I say don't do it and I've been in coquí
situations where I could see it coming
on
and I mean let her yeah but before it
even happened oh dude some guy in New
Orleans one time had indoor head [ __ ]
locks on his bathroom
this guy gets me into the bathroom we're
doing some cocaine after the Super Bowl
or something and next thing I know they
have two doors in the bathroom you know
and he puts a [ __ ] bolt on one of
them and I'm like Jesus dude now look
over the other one it has a bolt on it
I'm like I'm out of here jack
you know and I thought about trying to
do a little more cocaine and then just
keeping my foot in the door wedge while
I did it but I was like [ __ ] I'm just
out of here because you don't know what
that guy had amoenus I don't know I
admit do you know what the place where
that happens the most bone you can hear
it happen in the distance is Los Angeles
yes yes this is the kind of place like
you know for as much as this as Los
Angeles and the people out here call out
like the rest of America for having
shitty values in this and at this place
is [ __ ] up jack
this place is the dark arts bro this is
people have no idea you know if you
really think about it and I'm not being
a funny guy here whatever to meet to
movement has slowed down a little bit
yeah thank God I lost momentum yeah I
was getting too out of control I have a
daughter I was raised by a single mom I
have a wife a ton of my friends of
females yeah and I feel for you but it
was getting I think what our Gento got
busted the [ __ ]
the underage kids yeah and then these
women came out against Kavanagh and that
you know 36 years in a long time I
changed a lot
oh yeah 36 year since 1982 I think of a
person I am alive changed four times
yeah I'm great you know that's number
one you can't take that away from a man
or woman in number two I think that you
know when you have your [ __ ] Cosby's
you have your Harvey Weinstein so Harvey
Weinstein was 10 times worse than what
we know right but ain't right in the
people that last night electrical
Ellucian and there's 20 more Harvey
Weinstein a hundred percent and there's
a lot of actresses hiding those men
still and they knew about him it's only
whenever the you know the thing the
gavel starts to fall in and affects
people's pocketbooks and [ __ ] that they
or they realize their money safe then
they'll chime on I love NBC they gave me
Sam for the Sun they gave me cheek on
demand that gave me News Radio they've
given me a lot of shows of life yeah but
think about that I want you to guys and
the people listening at home to think
about that mm-hmm
NBC knew about Bill Cosby again MBC knew
about Bill Cosby right but they didn't
give a [ __ ] because of the money he was
generated yeah okay that goes with any
sport Conor McGregor could do whatever
the [ __ ] you well yeah would you
generate that type of money you want to
come on at the weigh-in with a bottle of
whiskey and a [ __ ] and give it to the
president of the [ __ ] league or
whatever he calls himself you know when
you're that type of person
Daniel white you could do whatever the
[ __ ] you want you know so yeah there's
20 Harvey Weinstein's yeah that dang we
have get in here but exposed yet or
nobody real John Weinstein dicks and
Weinstein look at this there's a bunch
of Weinstein's that have not been
exposed at RIT now yeah I went away
quietly into the night and said you know
what we got away with this for a long
time that nobody came out
yeah a weird one you know one thing
to notice when it was a you know I think
there's a lot of comedians out there
that start to use it as a not even
comedians I mean I guess there's just
it's uncomfortable when you start to
feel like and I just try to trust my
instincts I know a lot of women or you
know taking advantage of I know dude a
lot of men get objectified by women as
well these days and people don't want to
talk about that you know and none of
that sounds like kind of a [ __ ] thing
to say but you know there's a lot of
women out there using men as they see
fit as well you know for different
things and you know the place yeah here
you know in a place yeah in LA it's a
penis and so I don't like it when you
get a lot of these you know fancy ladies
saying oh feminism this and feminism
that but they're just selling books and
[ __ ] to you you know I'm saying
they're just peddlers they don't give a
real [ __ ] about anybody but themselves
and I you know that's one thing I hope
technology at one point can like tell
people's hearts you know like I hope at
one point like a Fitbit you could wear a
Fitbit that tells you like if that
person actually has any genuine care in
themselves for you you know and I think
that that's when technology is really
gonna help us cuz right now we're out
here [ __ ] around you know people
jerking off guys addicted to their own
you know semen and everything all of
this [ __ ] on the internet and it's just
you know we're in the rotgut stages of
Technology right now we're still
learning about this [ __ ] we're in a
place that's yeah the meatiest thing was
- stuff - it was - well here's I just
wanted to get this point out sorry to
interrupt you Joey um girls started
asking me can I come on the road with
you to open for you right and I was
afraid to have let them come with me
because I don't truck that's what that
movement kind of did to me because I've
always tried to value women yes like
have I I'm sure I've objectified women
before sexually you know and wanted you
know to be with a woman just for sex or
had sexual interests you know like lead
some of my thoughts I think some of
that's limbic and a man you're gonna you
know if I see a woman I don't you know
my first thought isn't like I'm gonna
you know buy her a house and just think
about her always my some of my thought
is in my day you know and that's nature
and that's mother nature put some of
your brain ins in the end of your dick
and the thing that gets me is like now
it's like women
anyway can could I come and feature for
you and it's like I don't know like
that's very scary like I've looked 2
years ago I'd have been like yeah I'll
give any woman like I don't have any
issue with it right I'm not gonna try to
[ __ ] this girl you know I respect her as
an artist but now I'm like what if this
girl has some crazy intention well no
you know will you take it on the road I
think that but it makes me second I
guess it quickly and Felicia Michaels I
know Naboth for years yeah yeah Kate oh
so I have no it would not turn me on the
[ __ ] Kate I love the death and she's
beautiful right a little sister yeah we
don't Felicia's like a sister to me
yeah so if I were on the road with a
woman that came up to me like I've had
women asked me and they that don't stay
at the hotel they stay at their own home
they live in Austin right with that I
have no problem I don't play that [ __ ]
at all I know what it's like to be a
young girl have a daughter and I
remember what it was like to what he is
you know what hey who can't stand me
right well I'm getting that I was
thinking about this the other day you
know cannot stand me you know you can't
mention my name around Chelsea him oh
she's the worst the first time I met
Chelsea and I went off on in a sexual
way he tried his pucker
she was [ __ ] gorgeous yeah she was
gorgeous I knew that at that time she
was doing drugs yeah she was opening up
for David Tao I was [ __ ] up on drugs
the yellower [ __ ] no what are you
[ __ ] [ __ ] are you [ __ ] crazy
no crazy would possible and I think evil
[ __ ] each other I think I didn't jump
from telling you you can't mention my
name around them I went to that black
Club she still wants to [ __ ] you no bro
stop trying to be funny I'm not trying
to be funny
there was no [ __ ] involved I was a
[ __ ] [ __ ] tour we were doing that
dumb black Club on [ __ ] J spot no the
other one at Union Station
Beverly Beverly Boulevard up down the
block of the chicken place they used to
be a club there one night and there was
how many Union comedy Union this had to
be 1998 bro and I was out there every
night with a package you know when I met
you were done
eat up Lauren [ __ ] with coke yeah
there we go she's there and I go to
economy you need to do a spot and I see
Chelsea hammer looking finer than a
[ __ ]
Mitch you have big breasts then at all
in 1998
Chelsea Handler was [ __ ] bangin so we
start talking she tells me how well
could she's very sweet to me yeah she
tells me what her credentials was and
not six minutes into the conversation
I'm like what's gonna rock a coke and
let me your [ __ ] is shit-faced her bail
me and she's crazy as it is but I knew
that I had done something wrong and then
three months later she was dating a
friend the mug
I went from black guy no white guy and I
went to a party and saw her and the look
she gave me was just horrid and after
that somebody came up to me one day they
go why did she hate you so much and I am
because one night she caught me you know
like just darling
women throw throw you off I'm saying
well yeah you have no idea how good she
looked that night yeah like this is what
Chelsea had the Volvo that's how that's
what she had the Volvo wow she was
banging she would go up to the store do
with 9-15 spot every night [ __ ] and
bragging but I had never met her before
yeah I'd never met her before I saw her
and we started talking
next minute we were talking about
cocaine and [ __ ] and next thing on my
trouser I taste
you look fine more than wow yeah let's
go somewhere do some blow as she was
like what the [ __ ] are you talking about
get the [ __ ] out you disgusting friend
slob really will you fatter
no I just just I was just you know a
gross person and I didn't know I was
doing coke yeah until this day you can't
mention my name or it's [ __ ]
hysterical but he stopped my honest
about it yeah I did groper or
our via I just asked the truth I'm gonna
suck you know I was oh yeah you know
came in from 98 to 2000 so
matteri 97 96 that was all I had I
wasn't a handsome guy yeah so I would
just say I got an eight ball of coke and
you got a [ __ ] what do you want to do
yeah you want to sit here talk to Lee
all night about [ __ ] computers but
yeah
oh you want to come up to the room you
little monkey eat with a co you said the
ten will go home dude I'm about to go
home with you don't say if you go up to
ten women and say that what he is gonna
take you up on your [ __ ] yeah you
only to throw again it was crazy
hunt that Fox with this yes rock it was
made looking crazy oh dude that was
craziest I remember yeah man and she
yeah I I remember she came into the I
was working at some club over there
these tough that when I moved to town
man I really started doing comedy in Los
Angeles you know when I really think
about it like I think the first time I
ever went up on stage was in New Orleans
but after that I just happened to be out
here I came out here to visit a buddy
and then next thing you know they had
comedy
I never living with my friend and they
had comedy down the street from us over
on San Vicente over in Brentwood and so
they had a place over there that guy
with the wooden leg used to run it
TJ's um white boys a comedy Marc Franco
and TJ mark somebody not TV Mark Walters
different TJ's but uh they it was two
blocks away so I walked down there on
Wednesday night and they started letting
me get up
but anyway bruco had a room over there
in Westwood in Chelsea Anna would come
in gym norm would come in and stuff and
this is Chelsea wasn't like famous or
anything then but she was kind of
popular you know she was a comedian was
always like real amateurs over there and
uh and yeah I just didn't like I went
and did her show one time and she
wouldn't even look at me and she just
treated me and then on social media and
stuff is like and social me he's not a
good way to judge somebody but you know
sometimes we do and she doesn't even
have any empathy for people there's
something about her that makes me seem
like she's just did the TV show fur yeah
how many times did you do it just one
time and what was her behavior towards
you she wouldn't look at me
you know she would talk to me well we
didn't look at me and she just made me
feel
I don't know she didn't make me feel
like welcome you know and when you're
young and you're nervous and I already
got nervous and I already you know the
industry like you know is never really
giving me much
you know this industry's never given me
much you know it's crazy to me you're
just getting a show over there at Fox
you know or I don't we can talk about
that or whatever but you know are an
opportunity for that you know it's like
it's crazy it's like just but anyway
I've always had that little bit of chip
on my shoulder maybe but yeah she just
made me feel like I don't know like I
wasn't funny or I wasn't good enough for
stuff like that you know there's nothing
worse than going on something and
somebody shot you wish you expected yeah
cuz I had expectations I had to expect
at least would be some niceness you know
like there's some excitement instead it
was like she's just kind of like this
this star this thing but now to me she
she I had this vision of her and this
could be wrong of like a lonely you know
older woman in like a castle with all
this money and she's just lonely
and I don't want anybody to end up that
way and that could just be me thinking
that way to make myself feel better you
know that she that I felt like she was
mean to me but I you know as she seems
like a real [ __ ] to me so whatever you
know you gotta give something up for
something you know and with Fame comes
you know I remember watching some
program in Jennifer Aniston said when
they shot the pilot for friends that to
celebrate the guy took the Vegas that
kind of producer took everybody of Vegas
Wow and then gave them each 500 oz that
said walk into a casino and gamble this
because that's the last time you're ever
gonna be able to walk through a casino
again
wow that's how big you guys it would be
you know they knew it out of the gate
huh they knew it out of the gate you
know and it's so weird how you that's
amazing listen man I was in this for so
long but I struggled for so long as a
human being
mm-hmm that no matter what you throw at
me now it wouldn't change yeah
like I'm done like yeah you already made
you
had me to go crazy when I was maybe up
to 32 yeah 33 34 yeah I would have got a
different crazy I would have got drugged
crazy at that age but I always knew what
I was what makes people crazy this time
it's nothing what they are mmm either
they did too much
mm-hmm or too little it's like being
somewhere where you don't belong
I always stress that because one day
you're gonna do that and you're gonna
see how bad you feel and you're gonna
think of me as a comedian or an actor
you know when you when you shoot a show
mm-hmm you ever shoot a show for
somebody in motion and you go to these
shows and you see the same [ __ ] comics
mm-hmm they're always coming by to say
hello
yeah yeah they provide it to this I came
in you look at them you gonna be shot
this showing or no and you feel bad for
them you go then why the [ __ ] are you
here cuz I shot this show what episode
and I feel bad I feel bad being like I
shot one scene in one show and I feel
like a [ __ ] [ __ ] so you didn't
even shoot the show but you're down here
doing what what is your purpose yeah
what is your [ __ ] purpose you look
like a [ __ ] idiot yeah yeah even free
food whatever you don't belong somewhere
do not be at that [ __ ] place yeah do
not be at that place you asked me it's a
question before you go to do you take me
on the road he's been doing comedy
Western a year yeah I didn't realize how
bad I do him any favors yeah it would
not do him any favors it would ruin it
yeah it would ruin him I know that he's
not ready by no means yes he's tweeze
away or I'd ruin his whole perception of
stand-up would be wrong take a point
that's a that's very perception I took
him to the wolf Edina he saw with its
life now the rest is up to him yeah he's
two years away from even stepping on the
stage of me on a plane yeah because I
know what it would do that yeah he needs
to go on his own now and go to Lexington
Kentucky and go to all the places
they've never seen a Jew yeah and do
that and jailor down brother do it three
years and you can do blackface if you're
Jewish I think
don't you guys get back you know I think
I'll hold off I just [ __ ] fired Kelly
Megan
now you gotta bring up blackfish my dick
isn't that tonight what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you I don't want to hear
blackface I don't want to talk about
blackface they just fired megyn kelly
and you want to bring up a blackface
you got great things happening in your
[ __ ] life leave blackface alone all
right
I just did enough Lee could do it no no
I'm gonna hold off on that one
no it's the truth yeah I would not be
doing him any favors oh you wouldn't be
in anything first guy that took me out I
was doing comedy for years yeah first
time I got taken out and I wasn't ready
but it was fraternities really yeah it
was who was it cuz they was Todd Jordan
they took me on like two or three or
four weeks of eternities every night it
was rush season mm-hmm whatever others
and he would have a different threat
every night to not to frats three frats
and I've been doing comedy for years and
I was just bomb I was like an Arab oh
yeah I was just going into places to
bomb and I would call a bomber you guys
are prepared you're gonna get a bomb I
wasn't ready
yeah and at that time that's all I
wanted and I would say to myself
whoo I'm happy I didn't get this call
two years ago I still remember going
like doing comedy a couple of months I
can go into an NBC no Johnny Walker the
liquor in the eighties and nineties if
you want to be anybody you had a win the
Johnnie Walker red competition of San
Francisco Wow that's what elevated you
every year
Johnny Walker did a national comedy
competition and it would end up on
channel 13 or something but you still
got national exposure yeah and now you
went into clubs that was one of the
credits it was either that the Tonight
Show or HBO oh yeah so that was the
explosion we talked him up the first
thing we talked Dorn taking on the road
so todd Jordan I took on you already
said I was almost ready bombings are you
or the other are but not saying that
yeah the three week camp Wow what that
is it's three weeks of doing comedy
every day three weeks five nights a week
and you get to adjust and that really
helped me right away that was a big push
when I finished those three weeks I was
a better comic line I was doing xxx I
don't trouble yeah I like the trimmer
ones for four years and that's a
complete different adjustment that's
every night you gotta just plus Drive
eight hours plus [ __ ] do radio but oh
yeah that's that's [ __ ] navigational
comedy you know sometimes you finish the
gig and drive that night cuz you got
made out of Drive I might as well get to
the whole town and all that you know it
teaches you how to deal with this yeah
that's what I saw already now yes you
not taking care of myself and not timing
things well a lot of people don't know
you know this there was a comic his name
was Doug Williams a great guy great guy
he created his show he got a Martin to
sign off on it
Wow and it was one of the first comedy
shows to go to stars stars was a black
network at the time and they had a
comedy series
hmm it did like three years that guy
today a friend of mine called me is
saying one of the cruise ship he saw
Doug Williams of the cruise ship
Wow what happened was Doug Williams got
he went to a roast
oh yeah and Jamie Foxx and Johnny Fox to
at all money that's gotta mean a Jamie
Foxx to you that very mean and Jamie
Foxx but the problem was he didn't
belong there he did not belong there who
Doug Williams didn't know he was nobody
to belong with he was too young to be up
there not too young he just didn't
belong that just did not belong in that
room he knew it but he was a guy bone
his eyes were bigger than his stomach
yeah and he went there anyway they got
burnt yeah and then I got everything
you cannot go somewhere we do that
belonging family or in life right if you
don't belong there don't go down there
cuz you're in trouble yeah that's a grip
man so really a really which stands up I
hate that [ __ ] when people say I'm up
there what do they call it I'm in the
light no what did they call when they go
on mingle there's a name for that
networking that works oh yeah give that
[ __ ]
yeah rub my balls on you now I never
been in network I'm like that working on
stage yeah you network on stage in
general is to talk to people I used to
be nervous when I were coming here I
used to be nervous or not like there's
some comedians that still make me kind
of nervous sometimes when I see them you
know to be around it's just because you
don't know him well you always look up
to him you know and then you see them
and it makes you nervous
well the one thing about the comic that
you look up to is when you go to the
store and you meet them and and this
happens the comics for me probably you
don't get the reception that you're
looking for yeah that's what I'm worried
about some of my idols I didn't get the
reception I was looking for so I didn't
talk to him I didn't talk to Andrew Dice
Clay for the first G I was at the store
and I'd see him up there five nights a
week
why because you want you in your place
yeah you're nothing to say to him I had
no circles that was saying yeah no no no
no you know and then you get emails from
people well it's terrible to meet your
heroes because you approached me the
wrong way yeah and at the wrong time
yeah there's a dude that comes up to me
a lot he's always kind of coked up I can
tell at the Comedy Store and now I hate
that guy coming around
we have no he knows it's uncomfortable
to him like why does he keep doing this
you know I don't judge people on the
drug aspect
I don't care sell me those drugs give me
a Ponzi schemes and [ __ ] ya know those
people I just didn't leave and I'd tell
them to get the [ __ ] out of my face I
don't want to hear about it well I'm
doing Konami I'm doing comedy bro yeah
and like this week I have a rough week
like that tonight and I'll be in New
York you know and that's my roughest
week because I have to deal with family
yeah got to talk to people you know I
got a tool I told you people where they
take the picture yeah can you paint the
window and I gotta talk to you for a
half hour I got a phone in the way they
say listen bro can you step aside and
let these but wait wait wait remember
the time we went no let these people
take the pictures and then you could
talk to me all you want it's very tough
for people to understand that yeah yeah
we're that's where I'm getting like it's
getting like you know I've been
struggling a lot with this cuz it's like
you know I love you know it's like you
worked so hard to get people to come out
and then people start
and you know it's a lot of like my
audience is dudes like me know that
their struggle with stuff are just
regular people you know good people you
know I feel like a lot of our audiences
are probably similar like good people
that come out to enjoy themselves you
know and I want to be able to spend time
with each one of them afterwards like
yeah so t-shirts as a regular person
yeah see I don't write because I want
them to be able to come to me and talk
to me and not to do that yeah yeah I saw
your future go online yeah
I'm not carrying t-shirts across the
country I'm military should I mail it
there and sell it still the same [ __ ]
point yeah because then again you have a
different complication now you have
people that feel now I bought a t-shirt
so now I'm gonna give you a [ __ ] now
I see what you're saying
I love time for any you beat them
between shows yeah I I need to focus in
between you want a good show from me
yeah
are you want a [ __ ] t-shirt right you
want a good show let's forget about the
[ __ ] t-shirt yeah I'll tell people do
not you don't don't feel obligated to
buy a shirt to come and say hey or two
but yeah just think about it would you
go say hang up my shirt for the money
it's not only I'd rather you not sell
the [ __ ] shirt and let them come over
and shake their hand yeah you know it's
like when people pay for the VIP
packages I feel bad for you yeah I feel
bad for you for two reasons I would
never charge to do a VIP package because
now I'm forced to talk to you and you're
forced to talk to me that's not a
relationship right that's [ __ ] I
would never sell a VIP package I want
you to come up to me after the show
take a pic to tell me what you got at um
and get the [ __ ] out of here yeah if you
pay me the 85 bucks of VIP that means I
gotta hear your [ __ ] a beating for
two hours yeah we don't have two hours
right I want you to come to the shows I
want you to enjoy yourself I want you to
take a picture we're gonna communicate
while we're taking a picture and then
you gotta go that's 200 people behind
you right you know I'm saying I don't
wanna I don't don't want to take money
from somebody to feel that I have to
talk to him after a show yeah so I get
come to a certain gated area I think
that is the most grossest because that
how do you hear that yeah you sell VIP
package and twenty people come to the
back afterwards talk to you and you take
a picture with them listen how about
do this how about I don't say your dick
you shake my hand we take a picture you
go your way I go my way yeah we talk for
two minutes you know you gotta be
considerable people right that's it and
most people are but here so here's some
thing that I'm running into right and so
this is a good thing I can ask you
actually because you have experience is
I'm noticing like so I'll go out after
the first show right and there's a line
like you say you know there's a hundred
and fifty people wanted to say hey I
want to meet me and I want to meet them
but then by the end of that I am so like
just exhausted emotionally bro that then
it's like the second show I found myself
being more temperamental because like
all of like your kindness and you're
just you're it's it you just feel a
little empty you know and I don't mean
that in a bad way like I don't care
about those people I don't it just gets
hard you know what I'm saying though and
am i complaining is that like just like
uh no you're not complaining
but people will listen to this have to
decide what they want I have to decide
what do I want
yeah me I want to see a [ __ ] great
show yeah when I go anywhere to a
concert anything I want to see a great
[ __ ] show man that's it yeah I want
to leave that going you know what my $26
was worth it my 2750 was worth so for me
to do that guess what sometimes number
one the shows are so bad yeah the staff
as soon as I get that Thursday they say
to me listen your sold-out Friday and
Saturday we only have one exit is there
any way you can't come out in between
shows no you know anything about me that
breaks my heart right yeah that's how I
feel you know you got a babysitter I
know you drove you paid the part I'm
aware of all these things yeah but guess
what I got to do best what's best for
the club and for the people for the
second show yeah somebody talked to my
wife and to me some t-shirts and I
noticed that that emotional hour in
between mmm was by the time I got stage
to the second show there was nothing
left
yeah that's what I'm starting to notice
a little bit people there's nothing left
there's nothing left the hug was the
kisses the pictures you go back in it's
show time now you're running late
because your people didn't get in
yeah that show starts 25 minutes late
that means there's 20 every time a
minute takes pass show time is one more
minute they'll be drunk right right yet
and there's not a babysitter's later
there was nothing that pisses me off
more than the club that starts to show
my yam either you want to not make me
come back to your club you thought of
Sholay 7 o'clock at 7:05 I understand
people driving Frank and 9:30 is 935
yeah I don't want to be on a stage at
12:30 at night for a 9 o'clock yeah I
thought that that's why what do you do
then what do I do
you know man if the first show is sold
out I cannot go out if the first show is
sold out the club does not want you to
go up and your fans are ok with that
they have to be yeah they have to be
went on the picture business we're in
the comedy business I'm in the business
of giving you the best show that I can
give you yeah so from being able to put
me to be able to do that eh I can't be
out there between show swing and shirts
with glasses on taking pictures you're
absolutely not right it draws your
energy yeah you know this is the week
that everybody wants to take me out to
dinner at 5 o'clock
Lisa at you know me a long time
you don't see me after fall yeah you do
not see me after fall I will when I go
in the morning I will buy a protein bar
yeah so I'm gonna have to leave my room
before I have to four o'clock yeah you
take a rest those three hours before the
shoulders on my time right I put my feet
up I watch an episode of sons of anarchy
yeah I hit the vapor pen and my notebook
is wide open and there's a pen close by
and I also got another notebook open
somewhere else for what is that what I
got I'm still my mind comedy over here
and the story over here Sons of Anarchy
over here a glass two things of water
a pack of nicotine gum yeah and a vapor
pen and that's what I do from four to
seven let's go huh show starts at 7:30
by 6:15 I start stretching
I throw some punches I turn the shower
on I let the shower get nice and hot I
start stretching a little bit just to
get my hobby yeah I asked Roberta
yeah how's what you do no I won't talk
to anybody
yeah hey how you doing I got you know my
agents they're great you sit here all
week
yeah come on Friday at 6:30 won't tell
anyone all yeah listen call your mother
on the Friday at 6:30 I'm only concerned
with the two shows yeah that's all I'm
concerned about and this of orchid boys
works best for you this is what works
best for me
yeah a great headliner once told me
mm-hmm
wait my nan once told me that if you
headline rest is the most important
thing for me to give the audience to
show I want yeah there's no den as it
for I'm not meeting you to smoke out I
mean nobody yeah I love me nobody
mananitas a lot I mean how you talk
about them will you pay 25 to 28 dollars
to see me yeah you don't see me out of
the hotel man
there's no this Thursday I gonna do a
part two podcast in New York you see the
shower head Friday and I'm back in my
room by one yeah and Friday I go to the
cemetery and bring flowers for my mother
yeah beside that nobody sees me the
reason why I stay where I stands coz
there's two of my favorite places in the
dead Laura yeah and this hotel has
breakfast for free yeah like that and
even though it's a half a Hindu hotel
yeah
eggs are good it's white bread and they
I don't feel that's [ __ ] out of this
world
hmm so I beliefs held over to one of my
friends could pick me up at then or I
take the [ __ ] bus and it to this city
or whatever huh every city I go as
planned that yeah but I never take away
from my show mm-hmm that means there's
no t-shirt yeah
there's no contact in between shows and
between shows I sit I reflect on the
last show and I reflect how the next
shows gonna be about interesting that's
it I don't care my mother's there I
don't care if your grandfather's coming
I don't really want to do much you
I don't really want to do much wow wow
wow game day is game day for us
people work hard for their dollar and I
have to give them their value for their
dollar and for me to give them the value
for that dollar hmm
I gotta take care myself yeah that's
what I'm struggling with right I gotta
take care boys so I'm feeling exhausted
so Friday night you stay up like Friday
nights my pill might if somebody gives
me pull up the show I take it I bring
back a protein bar maybe a [ __ ] a
Nana a banana or maybe I have an apple
from the lounge I go upstairs like drink
soda and I watch two or three episodes
or something I have no curfew on Friday
night yeah that means Saturday more wake
up nice and early I eat breakfast a nice
breakfast I smoke a joint I go for a
nice walk at 8:00 8:30 I go for a half a
mile walk mm-hmm just to let my body
know my life I go back to the room I
watch a little Netflix I pass out for
another three hours now I get up take a
shower and I go for a nice lunch a nice
cut of salmon yeah but my salad water
you take good care yourself yeah and you
go back to your hotel room were you
right for now yeah and while that hour
you're right and you're digesting your
meal uh-huh so now at 4:30
you go down to the hotel chip yeah and
you stretch on either 25 minutes on the
elliptical ten minutes on the bicycle
then you draw some weights around for 45
minutes you get that funk out of your
system now that Energy's office now
you're you're you're building your own
energy yeah and you're working on your
own sheet yeah you're not letting the
world is give you a no I don't want any
stupid stories jack I got tired but I
rather not have physical contact all day
and Lee knows anybody who goes on the
road with me they know they see me for
breakfast lunch I don't see you till
post time yeah I read it that I don't
want to see nobody yeah man that's it
and that's the best show I can give you
as Joey Diaz
if I deter from that plan we don't have
a good show so after the second show
you'll do two pictures and stuff yes
after the second show I'll do the pig
maybe I need to start trying that
because that has been your honesty I
know a thousand people don't do dick
there's a thousand people out there who
don't do dick I will take pictures with
you before shows I have a superstition
not because one time in Columbus a
hippie hugged me and he had armpit of
debt oh yeah they got on my shirt and
while I was on I think I grilling cheese
is I can smell [ __ ] onions for two
shows now when I took pictures of people
people looking at me like I smelled yeah
you know you it takes a long time to
come to terms with timely by the way I
always wanted to thank you for
supporting me on the Netflix special you
had uh please showed up you shut up on
your own dime you saw their response has
been good huh the response has been
great but it's really weird I'm even for
that I had too many distractions yeah
yeah in hindsight even thinking about
that it's I'm sorry you see the like man
that's like a lot of restrictions oh
wait I stick to my own stay yeah in the
future stick to what we give away for me
to give you a good show I have to do
things please
I know I know your mother cooks the best
chicken I know you do that that's all
great you know I really don't give a
[ __ ] I really don't give a [ __ ] when I
get off a plane that's when people
contact me on the road to do a podcast
I'm on your town to do a podcast yeah
we're gonna happen yeah some guys some
group you offered me money to divide me
I did my two podcast for the week that's
it when I go on the road I want to do
nothing all I think about stand-up
comedy and how I can make him better
before before I go to a town I Wikipedia
I Yahoo yeah check box of schools you
got a good Muay Thai school my pop in
their lights added more I got I meet
some people have some a little contact
with data with some new people yeah and
you blow their mind they blow your mind
and you're still back in your hotel room
by two o'clock yeah that's me a shower
you Reiji you gotta take good care
yourself when you're a feature it's a
different story when you're an emcee
it's a different story the world don't
fall on your shoulders
yeah you could go to watch the Baltimore
Ravens and go to a game the world
fall on your shoulders you just doing
ten minutes when you're a feature after
you think I gave a [ __ ] when I was a
feature I will have to dinner yeah oh
think I don't give a [ __ ] you can
[ __ ] to a fault I don't give a [ __ ]
but when you pay and I got a [ __ ] you
got a babysitter and you pay the part
yeah and all those variables I gotta be
at the top of my game there you go
that's the ghost telling you I love it
that I check times out to be on your
phone is Jen late it's getting late
Giovanna I love you need eight you want
to promote my brother um any dates that
I want to promote yeah I'm gonna be in
Lexington great club yeah lemons
Broadway great club yeah
great food the great hotel yeah great
city great city in December that's what
I'm gonna be on there so I'm excited
that I'm going there in in December
world's January don't worry about
genuine best I could
you've got assumed that can remember and
then yeah what else oh I got your AIA
favor was on I was on my Potter's I'm
this past weekend so you can check that
as well and I just want to say thanks so
much Joey you're always such a you know
uh you know you're just a nice man and
you always make me feel welcome and you
know you call me a lot and I just I know
that you care and and and I really feel
that and I just I don't know thank you
so my blood I care about what I can feel
at that but it some people say that kind
of shitty or whatever but I'm just
telling you so I appreciate it man I
know you do thanks boys and I love you
Lena I'm sorry that I'm if I made funny
when I got in this tough this damn oh
yeah we do took [ __ ] nine fart bro is
[ __ ] geez like Iwo Jima over your on
is no that's a death sentence my judges
tell you either for farts of 90 days
yeah and most people take them 90 days
yeah this for this poor Jewish tank sack
then took five of the words hahaha can
you've ever smoked and you're [ __ ]
leavin I'm sitting here going Jesus
Christ my intestines about to pop out of
my ass like anyway I love you guys with
all my [ __ ] heart man I want to thank
the O Vaughn I want to thank my main men
the Christ killer who I love with all my
heart hoping
Afeni with the comedy line tool and i
just wouldn't be doing you any favors i
would take you somewhere and then you'd
still have to go back and do the work
and then you'd be more mad at me so you
always got to understand I got your back
in more ways than one
thank you very much for always being a
great [ __ ] sidekick and a friend and
a dear supporter of what we do and I'm
very proud of you for doing comedy and
when the time comes you're gonna be
right there with me some good luck to
you and your Venture you know I love you
to death and I support you I break your
balls but I break your balls out of love
I don't know that I understand that but
don't break your balls they break your
balls to be you I'm you know I love you
all my heart but anyway forget that love
I got for this [ __ ] Jew I love them
with all my heart that's my problem I
got a soft spot for Jews I don't know
what Jews and black people are doing
anything for you but listen this podcast
is brought to you by rich like I said in
the beginning ridges and minimalized
front pocket wallet that helps you
really ate your everyday carry launched
by a father-son team and funded by
Kickstarter in 2013 the ridge now
resides in the pockets of over a quarter
of a million men and women listen my own
wallet was stacked with [ __ ] the kind of
[ __ ] were you carrying around for
months and years say whatever you want
to hear you gotta get rid of that [ __ ]
talk about all the pointless stuff that
we carry in our wallets receipts hotel
room keys hookers addresses spent gift
cards get rid of all that [ __ ]
don't let the blindfolds menus resemble
suitcases more than wallets the ridge
helps you carry less but always what you
need right listen
I love the rich personally when I travel
that's what I got that at the ridge two
credit cards a PBA card and my ID and
I'm ready to go so do me a favor like I
said it's minimal its front pocket
wallets at designed to help you ditch
your bulky wallet the ridge wall is slim
RFID blocking and it has a lifetime
guarantee and it's gonna be the last
wallet you'll ever own
so do me a favor what I'm gonna do for
the church family today
first off go to Ridge comm check out
what I'm talking about you're gonna be
blown away number two if you get
something I'm gonna give you ten percent
off with free worldwide shipping by
using Ridge wallet dot-com slash Church
again that's Ridge wallet dot-com slash
Church and use promo code Church to link
in the description all right listen
Ridge wallet will make a great present
you're gonna love it with all your heart
okay number three I love you guys
these guys are tremendous my wife has
been using them for years and again I
got nothing against nobody but time is
time and if you're saving time you get
postage and demand all you need is
stamps calm with stamps calm you got all
the services you got at the post office
right up from your desk you can buy and
print real US postage for any letter or
any package all available 24 hours a day
seven days a week
just click print and mail ba boom you're
done stamps.com we even send you a
digital scale you can weigh your letters
and packages and print the exact amount
of postage every time I love it my wife
uses to sell out the cups the t-shirts
we've been using for years and I'll tell
you I give him a hundred percent
recommendation whether he have a small
business or a large business I'm telling
you right now whatever you're doing and
you've your mailing out stuffs stamps
calm is what you need so right now your
uncle Joey is gonna give you a special
offer you ready grab a pen I'm gonna
give you a four week trial includes
postage at a digital scale but don't
wait gonna stamp stop calm before you do
anything else right now right now I was
sitting there click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage and type in Joey
Jo ey again that's Joey Jo ey on the top
of the homepage again that stands calm
and - Joey I want to thank rich I want
to thank stamps.com and I want to thank
quit ok
because quit
again the best toothbrush I've had in
years Equipe was designed to make
brushing your teeth and was simple and
affordable but most importantly
enjoyable like I said I've used it the
last four days my mouth feels cleaner my
teeth are still chartreuse because God
knows what I put in my mouth but
everything feels fresh and clean my
breath smells like dog [ __ ] there's
nothing you could do about that as long
as your teeth are clean why do you use
quip says sensitive sensitive sonic
vibrations
gentle enough to use on sensitive gums
people who brush too hard sometimes like
the two brushes are too abrasive it's
built with a two minute timer that
pulses every 30 seconds to remind you to
switch sides helping you guy in a full
and even clean why cuz up to 90% of us
don't brush for the first for the full
two minutes or don't clean evenly it's a
multi-use cover mounts to cover your
mirror and on monster slide over
bristles to go on to brush it three out
of four of the bristles to the old worn
on and ineffective clip is one of the
first electric toothbrushes then
accepted it's accepted by the American
Dental Association and has thousands of
verified five-star reviews why I love
quip dependable it's right there and I
can take it on the road and that's what
you're looking for with a toothbrush so
do me a favor the big favor is this I
love clip so much and they're backed by
twenty thousand twenty thousand dental
professionals clip starts at 25 begins
and if you go to quick calm slash joy
right now you get your first refill pack
for free wit equip electric toothbrush
who's better than you you're gonna have
a nice smile at the holidays you know
I'm saying you don't got to go to
Thanksgiving and cover your mouth
because your teeth the green you got a
nice clean fresh face more confidence so
do me a favor go to quip comm slash joy
right now and get you a little [ __ ]
quick toothbrush for $25
no they started 25 hours and if you go
to quit right now you'll get your first
refill back for free with equipped
electric toothbrush that's how uncle
Joey takes care you before the holidays
I want to thank quip I want to thank
stamps calm and I think want to thank
Ridge for sponsoring the podcast but
most importantly I want to thank you
people for two things for supporting the
degenerates and for supporting our
podcast for the last 7 years you know
who you are from Bob willingness to
Bobby Sheeran to the goose to [ __ ] my
man the Greeks up in Canada I'm watching
you and over the [ __ ] you are my little
convenient in Vegas who I love to death
Freddy Correa I love all you
[ __ ] so if I forget to say
somebody my man Scott coming in I love
yous all thank you for the support thank
you for the support on the on the
Netflix special and I'll see you
[ __ ] next Tuesday ready to
[ __ ] rocking great witness awed
gasp Lee kick this [ __ ] wheel stay
black mani